qatar's 2022 World Cup will be played
across eight different stadiums let's go
check them out
first up we have elbait Stadium host to
The tournament's Opening match it's one
of the largest venues holding up to 60
000 fans and its design was inspired by
betenside tents used by qatar's nomadic
tribes and others across the region
altumama Stadium holds up to 40 000 fans
its circular shape was inspired by the
gaffia a traditional woven cap that's
commonly worn by boys and men across the
region
Stadium what's special about this one is
that it's the first temporary stadium in
World Cup history it's made out of 974
recycled shipping containers after the
World Cup is over it's all going to be
dismantled so it can either be rebuilt
in a different country as one big
Stadium or several other small ones El
janub stadium is located near a former
fishing town called alwakra its design
was inspired by qatar's traditional Dao
Pearl fishing boats paying tribute to
the area's Maritime history
and then there's Education City Stadium
Ahmed bin Ali stadium and Khalifa
Stadium
and the biggest of all is this blue sail
Stadium blue sail seats up to 80 000
fans its exterior is based on designs
seen in Golden decorative bowls and
other art across the region and was
built at a cost of around 760 million
dollars this is where the final will be
played in that World Cup trophy will be
won